what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can't decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in and the
foreseeable feature
rob Corman y'all know what I'm getting
ready to say Batman the best thing comes
out of DC rebirth right now oh my god do
this story is so good man this story is
so good like Tom King man and taste man
this man is living up to his namesake
he's the king of writing Batman right
now mostly because he's the only one
right in the Batman comic Detective
Comics is good Detective Comics is
amazing
love Detective Comics but this right
here with Batman is amazing in all
seriousness stuff this is a beautifully
written comic I mean a beautifully
written comic because there's no like
villains
there's no bane coming there's no rule
the Joker no none of that stuff
this is Batman at his most real this is
Batman like Batman's characters tangible
you can feel it the cool thing about
this is this really kind of offers like
a follow-up to the whole events with
Gotham girl and it was always like this
unresolved plotline right like his
things been going on forever and ever
and ever and ever and has just never
really been resolved even now we still
don't know a lot about her all we really
know is that in the beginning of Batman
rebirth that Gotham and Gotham girl had
just shown up in Gotham City and they
had these powers that made them almost
akin to Superman they could fly they had
durability and hand strength so on and
so forth now over the course of the
story Gotham of I am Gotham what we have
learned is that somewhere along the line
they had effectively sold years of their
lives in relation to power which meant
that if you wanted like absolute powers
you would have to basically say here's
the X amount of years that I'm willing
to give away what that really means is
that the more she uses her powers the
more she drains years off her life and
so she's kind of at this impasse because
if she decides to become a superhero
she's going to start losing more of her
life if she doesn't she can live out the
rest of her days or whatever day she has
left as a person and that's really the
crux of this story in a lot of ways with
the exception of the ending but the cool
thing about this is that with the
character of Gotham girl because she's
so powerful she was one of these people
that basically had her emotions messed
with by psycho-pirate and so as a result
she spent most all of the storylines
after the events of I am Gotham she
spent all the other storylines just kind
of sitting in fear now of course this
was really kind of Kings way of putting
around the backburner
I'm just saying hey look we're going to
save her for later but for right now if
we have somebody fighting as part of the
bat family then had strength and power
that basically made them equivalent to
Superman then it would just solve all
the problems that are coming
long Batman fights bane gum fangirl
swoops in and saves the day it would
cause all kinds of issues cuz fans would
be like waters in Gotham girl just do
anything so it allows her to be put on
the back burner but having recovered
from her whole experience with regards
to the the mecha nations of
psycho-pirate puts her in a position now
to where she can basically decide what
she wants to do next because it's really
kind of a fresh start for her and the
cool thing about this is that it really
asks all these important questions with
regards to Bruce Wayne as a character
because what Gotham girl kind of
pondering what she's going to be met is
she going to be a superhero is she going
to be a normal you know live a normal
life she asked these questions to Bruce
Wayne because he's really the first
guidance that she's ever really had and
being a superhero keep in mind Gotham
girl in Gotham gained their powers they
decided the one they wanted to be
superheroes but they didn't have any
real training didn't go to the Justice
League and say teach us how to be
superheroes Batman was the first time
they encountered a superhero and Batman
is a very unique case among the
superhero community because he's so
capable but he's also just mortal all it
would take is for someone to know Bruce
Wayne's identity and then to be sitting
on a rooftop on a building somewhere
with a sniper rifle Bruce Wayne gets out
of his car he goes to walk into Wayne
Enterprises he gets shot in the head and
that's the end of Batman I mean that's
all it would take a story like that
wouldn't be very fun like it's just the
death of Batman that things three pages
long it would not be interesting at all
but you know that's that's what it takes
for this character but he's so unique
he's so interesting because he's so
smart he's so easily killed that's what
makes the thing so cool about him but in
a lot of ways he's also the first
superhero that Gotham Girl has really
encountered they can teach her what it
means to be a superhero to go out and
live a normal life and it's kind of
interesting you know because she asked a
question what would I do like you know
where would I go and it's kind of funny
because she says I was hoping he would
just point me in the right direction I
was hoping that all this would be done
to my emotions to be back under control
you know you would give me a piece of
paper and say follow these rules and
you'll have a normal life that's what
she was hoping for was for him to
basically hold her hand and guide her to
where she needed to go to become a hero
but at the end of the day it's not like
that because it's not like that for
anyone there aren't there's no rulebook
on how to live life there's no guidebook
on what you should do and what you
shouldn't do them it's not like you're
born you know and then you get to the
point where you go through elementary
school and middle school and high school
you know when you're ready to go off to
college you get you're 18 years old you
get your first job and your parents say
okay here's the book of life have fun
and all you have to do is just go
through the pages as you encounter
situations
to pay bills what credit means I mean
there's no guidebook for that kind of
stuff I think I'm gonna start a YouTube
channel like rah just where I do that
the the guidebook to life I have no idea
but nonetheless you know these are
things that she's literally learning not
for her the idea of paying bills things
like that I mean that's not essential
but you guys understand what I'm saying
there's no guidebook on how to be a
superhero and that's the kind of crazy
thing is because that's why each member
of the Justice League is so significant
you know despite the fact that he's
basically the security guard slash guy
that hangs around you know and just like
watches whatever he washes on TV black
mirror I have no idea
cyborg plays a role in the Justice
League Superman is the backbone he's the
guy where everybody knows no matter how
bad things get it's not over unless
Superman's incapacitated Wonder Woman
the one who will fight until the bitter
end
Batman is the brains of the operation
Green Lantern's he's the one that's like
look if things get really bad I've got a
whole army behind me but I can just
bring in to unleash absolute health
everybody has a role to play with Gotham
girl she's figuring out her role she's
figuring out her life she's really kind
of just having this existential crisis
right now she doesn't know where she
belongs
she doesn't know who she's supposed to
be here what she's supposed to be about
and Batman said that Batman says look
when it came down to it following the
death of my parents sure Alfred said hey
look here things that you're supposed to
do you know here's how you live your
life here's how you become a man but
when it came to him becoming a superhero
there was no guidebook Batman did the
best he could he suddenly came across a
guy who was dawning this Red Hood they
got into a fight Red Hood fell into of
that and became the Joker you commit to
actions you do things they have
consequences and you navigate and chart
those waters as best you can but the
funny thing about this is that this
creates a lot of questions in the mind
of Bruce Wayne remember we did the
button at the end of the button or
during the events of the button he came
face to face with his own own father
Thomas Wayne but that version of Thomas
was more significant than the actual new
52 version of Thomas it was shot in that
alley and the reason why is because the
flashpoint version of Thomas flame saw
his son died he saw that version of
Bruce Wayne killed his wife Martha Wayne
became the Joker these are the kind of
things that he dealt with
and so when he sat down with Bruce and
he said go live your life do not live
your life as Batman do not live your
life fighting crime go and live a life
go make a life for yourself find a woman
settle down our family
knowledge on to the next generation
let's somebody else be Batman go and
live what he's finding himself doing
here is reiterating that exact same
advice to Gotham ville and she's in turn
asking well then why don't you follow it
if that's advice that you think it's so
sound that this advice that you think
it's illegitimate then why aren't you
following it and this is the beauty of
all this this is this is the beauty of
the whole conversation that they have
Batman says because I don't know how to
not be Batman I don't know how to be
anybody else that's who I am that's what
I am my parents were shot in an alley
I'm terrified you know that I'd have to
relive that experience I'm terrified of
losing the things I care about the only
way for me to cope with that situation
is to become Batman that and became an
ingrained part of Bruce Wayne so much so
that Bruce Wayne is the costume is the
face he puts on when he goes out in
public when the Sun Goes Down when the
criminals come out Batman comes out and
that's who Bruce Wayne really is he
doesn't know how to be anything else and
that's what's so cool about this is
because it's hitting home it's telling
us the one thing that we as Batman fans
always knew it didn't take a genius to
know that like Batman was the character
of Bruce Wayne is just the guy that we
see occasionally that's just that's the
way it's always been but it's so cool
just kind of see that thrown on you know
in pen and paper and ink that that's
what it is that Bruce Wayne is just he
doesn't know how to be anybody else but
Batman not only that the idea of failing
to him is a massive calamity it's
something that he's absolutely terrified
of not only that while he tries his best
to live a normal life while he tries his
best to do the things that ultimately
work for him at the end of the day he's
afraid of what it means to not be Batman
and because of that he fails he
basically sets himself up for failure he
sits down in his home in the comfort of
his own home
front of a fireplace with a glass of
scotch and that's the question I wonder
what life would be like if I wasn't
Batman
but he looks around the city of Gotham
and he says I'm the last bastion of hope
here I'm the last man standing I'm the
last fig-leaf if I stop being Batman
this city gets overrun the cops can
hardly do the job on their own the only
reason why their city is where it is now
is because I operate outside of the law
that can bend the rules I can break the
rules I can make people talk who
wouldn't talk I can make people talk who
wouldn't talk to the cops
they wouldn't be able to get the
information they need I can swoop in and
the dead of mine I can make people so
scare to commit crimes that they don't
rob banks so they don't mug people
the streets some do but at the end of
the day the biggest threat to the city
of Gotham of the big guys that Joker the
penguin two-face those are the kind of
things that we have to worry about and
so in a lot of ways he's done his job
but his biggest fear is that if he steps
down and he walks away then Gotham is
just right for the pickings word gets
around the Batman's gone oh my god
Batman's gone through the city is ours
and suddenly it just descends into
absolute madness and so while he wants
to live a normal life he can't because
he fraid he's afraid that if he does
he'll fail the city of Gotham and if he
fails the city of Gotham she'll fail his
parents and that again is why it's also
important because at the end of the day
it's like that same line it's like the
line that we saw in injustice to that
thread doesn't change no matter what
universe we're in if Batman or I'm sorry
of Bruce Wayne is Batman then it's the
same thing all the time no matter what
he looks like no matter what you know
huge calamity he's engaged in no matter
what enemy he's fighting or how big his
Justice League team is at the end of the
day the man under that cloak encou is a
little boy who's crying because his
parents got shot in an alley that's
what's so cool about it and that's what
makes it so interesting is because
that's who Batman is and so taking this
advice you know when he says look this
conversation is not about me and you
know Gotham girl says that's the problem
the conversation is not about you we
need to make it about you Batman has to
really ask himself took a good look at
the mirror and say am I really doing
everything I can to live a normal life
am I am I really in this position where
I've tried everything that I can and so
what he ends up doing is he goes to
Catwoman and this is why you're so
gorgeous because it's not like a
knee-jerk thing it's not like you know
King was sitting right in the stories
like you know what I wonder what would
happen it's like that and proposed to
Catwoman let's just see what suspicious
have it come out of nowhere now it's a
gradual work in it's a gradual thing it
starts you know really all the way back
I would dare say with Scott Snyder's run
but it really picked up steam with
Batman rebirth it starts with the
introduction of Gotham of Gotham girl
the possibility existing did that man
can train these two new people so that
he can go and have a life for himself
only to find out that one of them goes
crazy ends up being killed by his sister
and the sisters emotions are manipulated
by psycho-pirate and she ends up having
to be taken care of and it's right back
to the way it was before right back to
the way things were before Bruce Wayne
has got to be Batman and he's got to
keep Gotham City safe and he's got to
Train do for whatever is it he's got
and then suddenly it's bane oh my god
Bane's back is the same thing over and
over and over and over again and then he
goes to Barry Allen it says hey let's
see some investigation about this button
eobard thawne shows up eobard thawne
just wreaks absolute havoc on Batman
disappears reappears rants about having
seen God Barry Allen and Batman jump
into the timestream
Batman runs into his own father Thomas
Wayne Thomas Wayne says go live your
life
the world the universe the multiverse is
screaming at Bruce Wayne go live a life
man quit being Batman go live a life go
do your thing and so what does he do he
finally after so many years follows the
universe's advice follows the
multiverses advice everybody says go
live a life and he does he goes to
Catwoman in one of the most beautiful
moments that I've ever seen in a comic
book
he goes to Catwoman it says from the
time I first met you I knew that you
were going to be the one whether it was
because opposites attract whether it was
because she was just so willing to do
whatever it took in order to pull off
whatever goal it was she was trying to
achieve at the end of the day he says
I'm terrified of what it is that I'm
about to do I'm so scared that I might
lose you the one connection that I have
to what it can mean to have a real life
I'm terrified of what it means to
possibly take this step because it means
I'm going to step down from the life
that I've had but regardless of it all
he tells Catwoman he loves her and he
proposes to work the reason why this is
so discipline will tell you that any way
any man who's ever proposed to a woman
will probably tell you it was the most
terrifying moment of my life because
what if she says no but for Bruce Wayne
it's not terrifying because maybe she'll
say no it's terrifying because of what
this represents it's terrifying because
of what this means but Bruce Wayne being
Batman the reason why he's kept so many
people at arm's length the reason why
he's kept so many people distant is the
possibility of losing them so much loss
in his life he looks around and says if
I propose to Catwoman if I take this
step if I lose her it could shatter me
it could break me in a way that I never
imagined but in the end he does it he
takes that step because he's ready for
something new
he's ready for a new era of his own life
and that's why this is so great because
what this does is it bolsters the Batman
story now because now he's got his own
Lois Lane he's got his own Mary Jane
Watson he's got his own a love interest
in his life that he has to hold on to
because she's now the closest thing he
has to what it means to live a normal
life but we are being said guys if you
new here to come this explained make
sure you guys have the sub button to
become part of the Rob core to guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like god this was an amazing story this
is actually gonna lead into the war of
jokes and riddles which I'm really
really excited about but oh my god was
this beautifully written
DC Comics Bravo Bravo
this was amazing is the best thing
coming out of DC rebirth right now
absolutely stellar I really hope that we
get more stuff like this it's one of
reasons why I love King's Batman so far
because it's just been astronomically
amazing and this is just the cherry on
top it's the icing on the cake
beautifully done absolutely beautifully
done anyway guys we're gonna go ahead
and bring this video to an end and that
will catch you all later peace
[Music]
you